but I should be and there's probably no
one watching right now but this is my
second day in a row testing out twitch
hopefully it works and hopefully can
entertain some people so I just took a
major hit to my Miley chest bullet
rating by losing about a hundred points
in less than one hour so my goal is to
hopefully get above 2,400 again and
maybe even break 2500 by the end of this
tournament a bit optimistic but we'll
see what happens
and I don't think there's anyone
watching right now but if there is if
you can leave a comment a comment in the
chat that would be awesome actually
there's one person watching right now
and that would be me so
Wow an international master ok whoever
sent that message I'm glad you're
impressed go for the Budapest that's a
great bowline opening actually this is
one of my favorite bullet lines
it's barely anyone knows what to do
against its
I win a piece I'd take on f3 you take on
D to take on anyone I don't want a proof
of that
okay let's just play it safe not
entirely safe but should still be good
for black I'm always happy with the
Queen trade
okay now the bad start still no one
watching okay
I think everyone's watching the Ben
Feingold Simon Williams match right now
so I'm not not too disappointed the
second opening second second time in a
row same opening this time the guy just
hangs a bishop that's nice just a matter
of not not slipping or blundering
and I really want to checkmate him rh2
okay
made it easy
think if next opponents below mm I would
preserve but this guy definitely not
there's irking with
I remember correctly this line isn't
that great for whites be greedy
slightly annoying always happy with the
Queen trade so I'm down the pond but not
even more and this should be just a
better ending
winning c3
while that's threatening me but in a
different universe I could have easily
lost that position still only one person
watching and one person is me so
hopefully by the end of this terminal
that's some at least a few viewers
yesterday had like six or seven viewers
its all-time record given it was my
first stream don't know if d5 works but
sometimes it's interesting okay didn't
mean to castle like that but the most
comfortable position for white actually
he's playing a little bit slow I'm
pretty happy structure is nice just
gonna push h5g six get some each file
action me five actually can't really be
defended another time so if he plays
rook 88 I take before is a decent move
though I take on h8 first probably not
okay it's gonna come down to sometime of
some kind of time Scrabble
[Music]
it's weird pawn structure I'll just flag
him where's my meat there we go okay
this first somewhat messy game okay
wasn't too serious too serious enough
towards the end there hey I have one
viewer Wow
whoever is watching this if you can
comment in the chat and tell me how you
found it and while you're watching
that'd be awesome this is intended to
just be a test stream and not really
anything too significant and if you are
watching this I would probably recommend
switching over to watch the the Ben
Feingold Simon Williams match unless
you're to want to young to watch it then
of course you can watch this very
positional game gonna be a lot of moving
around try and make make it a little bit
tactical it's usually a good sign when
most of your opponent's pieces are on
one side and their King is on the
complete opposite side feel like mate
should be very close maybe not
okay simple enough oh maybe not
Wow it's actually kind of annoying I'm
still not mating that easily or am I
like 97 was a better try I'm really a
lot of time okay start pre moving I'll
have to go back and see there probably
should have been like a much easier way
to win that I'm back down the one viewer
I guess left probably followed my advice
so okay pretty clean tournament so far
let's play this kind of trying to you
opening
hmm to look up this line might just be
winning upon though can take their let's
play Bishop h6 a lot of cases can go for
some quick meaning ideas probably not in
this case for trading Queens I know
that's a lot more positional actually
I'm just winning a pawn on c7 the one
problem for me is most of my pieces are
not developed but if I can develop
enough plunder I should be simply better
mmm through this Wow
okay so he was uh pretty moving a bit
too much there
I do have to be careful oh no that's
messy but it works so one okay to
viewers watching one of them is me
whoever is watching if you can leave a
comment I'm very curious like who you
are and like why exactly you're watching
this not the that Ben Feingold Simon
Williams match
it's kind of a weird structure but
blocking is actually very safe just in
the center like this let's take first
let's pile up
I forgot to visit there the rule is if
they're under under 2000 so desert let's
try and remember for next time oh my
gosh
I was terrible
I was even more terrible okay so my goal
for this tournament is to break 2500 but
despite winning all my games it's still
going to be a tough task like this game
taking a big risk
classic trap
okay smooth up to three viewers Wow if
you guys can comment in the chat that
would be awesome and subscribing is even
better but I'll try not to tell you what
to do this is my third time playing the
Buddha passes tournaments new line let's
do this I probably should have taken it
it's still fun position this trap the
Knights it works let's move back
winning a piece and trading Queens Ruby
five in Bishop f6 okay well done
this is actually kind of annoying it's
my king is stuck
[Music]
oh my gosh that's rough
a guy played well to come back that game
though got a little too uh too
comfortable it's been a lot of similar
openings as tournaments like a lot of
people just don't know how to play
against this time on our Sicilian
[Music]
I'll take right
and see that move
oh wow let's be tricky okay
I think if you play like rook f2 there I
don't know how I'm stopping Queen h6
maybe I have like King h8 and rook g8
but it would have been tricky okay so
I'm leading the tournament after losing
one game still way ahead of second place
seven minutes left
oh let's play this line my secret
opening nice thing about this position
we basically traded the the G pod for
the e pawn so it's just like a good
version of some Dutch where black can't
play e5 be a bit careful about and I
take d4 yeah I guess might take to you
for oh I'll win the e pawn maybe maybe
not okay there we go
have a lot of time to make up
you know he was playing well for a good
portion of the game putting a lot of
pressure but just had to survive okay
let's play mainline h3
it's a bit annoying night is kind of
like a dead piece but g5 can be pretty
strong occasionally okay so he's hacking
upon going for open files usually the
strategy is if they attack you on the
side you should just respond in the
center
to be careful
still the three viewers two of which are
not me not sure if you guys are like
twitch users but if you comment in the
chat we can interact and I might
actually do a similar thing other than
play bullets but we'll see
and yeah if you're new to this channel
it's because my first stream was uh was
yesterday and I'm still kind of learning
how to operate twitch and I'm not even
sure if like the microphone is working
and if the the the screen is being
shared properly but I think it should be
okay I guess I'm sagging upon but not
really to watch out for his tactics 2.94
I just want to simplify house mean oh my
gosh how is this happening
wow that was brutal
the sound is normal thanks for
commenting Liliana boullion okay looks
like I'm gonna finish first but wasn't
the strongest finish I was hoping for
well let's be tricky threatening worked
a cage too he saw it or at least
defended by accidents
oh my gosh that's so bad very bad finish
I did win but I guess that last game
didn't count for the tournament anyway
that was really just as a test stream
for me I wasn't really aiming to to be 2
- interactive or even get too many
followers I think there's two people
still watching I think what I'll do now
is can either continue with bullets or
do a simultaneous imal so forever for
whoever is watching I hope you had some
enjoyment with that and I will be back
soon bye